okay uh thanks everyone uh
to joining uh today's seminar um
before i formally or informally
introduce um today's speaker uh some
logistics
for all of you please mute yourself
during the seminar unless you have a
questions and if you do have a question
please use the chat room
and obviously no classified discussion
today
and that's about it and
otherwise just enjoy the talk
all right let me introduce
today's paper i'm super happy to
have dr trijar here with us
virtually i have known her quite a long
time so i can introduce her somewhat
informally
uh dr tuzera and i went to the same
school and the same
program for phd that is icme
at stanford university back then she was
famous or somewhat notorious for her
diligence
and academic achievements she was
getting
all a plus on the courses that we were
struggling to even pass and survive
no need to say that we were jealous of
she has continued her reputation until
today without surprise
she is now a principal member of
technical staff at sandia national
laboratories
actually across the street from us she
has
made many great achievements so far you
can check out them in
our bio but just give you one great
achievement
in 2019 dr suzer was
awarded the presidential early career
over
the scientists and engineers for
developing new
impactful mathematical methods and
computer algorithms
to enable real-time analysis control
and decision-making on computationally
prohibited problems
relevant to the nuclear security mission
and climate modeling
without further ado let's now hear a
great talk on the
schwarz alternating methods as a means
for concurrent
multi-scale coupling in solid mechanics
there you go arena so are you ready
thank you youngster for the invitation
and for the um
you know way too flattering of an
introduction
i think but um it's really a pleasure to
have the opportunity to give a talk um
obviously i'd prefer to do it in person
but um you know it's
good to be able to do this virtually
even in these um very strange times
um so uh as young suicide i'm going to
be talking about
the schwarz alternating method as a
means for concurrent multi-scale
coupling and solid mechanics this is
something i've been working on for about
six years now um so i'm in the
quantitative modeling and analysis
department um
at sandia california across the street
from um from you guys
and this is with a couple of my
collaborators with rails department also
in san diego california and um greg
flippel who was a summer student we had
um
a few years back who's currently at msc
software and
at newport beach so let's um oh let's
see
why is this not oh here we go okay um so
here's the the outline for the talk
um so i'm i'm going to start by
giving a little bit of motivation and
background for
why we're interested in concurrent
multi-co-coupling methods
and kind of why we've selected the
schwartz
framework as a means to achieve this
coupling
the main part of the talk is going to
have two parts
so the first part is going to focus on
some of the earlier work we did in
developing the method for the case of
concurrent multi-scale coupling
for quasi-static problems and solid
mechanics and then the
the second half is going to be on some
more recent work we've been doing
in extending the method to dynamics um
so for each of these i'll um
go through the formulation of the method
i'll talk a little bit about the theory
i'll talk about implementation of the
method and two codes um
albany lcm and t are solid mechanics and
then i'll show
numerical examples so this this talk is
definitely heavy on the numerical
examples um
you know hopefully those will give you a
sense of some of the properties of the
method
and
the types of problems you can use
domestic call
um um so you know there should be some
time for questions i may kind of stop
and ask her questions in between the
section
um so we can kind of play that by a year
okay
so uh the first thing i wanted to um to
discuss is a little bit of motivation
and background so
i'll start with um motivation for
um developing and using concurrent
multi-skill coupling
uh methods um so essentially a lot of
the
the problems that are of interest to um
sunday national labs and
i think this is certainly true for
lawrence as well um
require us to simulate and understand
the large-scale structural failure of
engineered components um so this comes
up a lot in some of our
nuclear deterrence type mission spaces
where you know the components may be
comprising
for instance weapons type systems um for
uh these types of uh problems what often
happens is a large scale structural
failure
frequently originates from a small scale
phenomenon such as a defect or a micro
crack
which grows quickly in an unstable
manner and can lead to the
ultimate large-scale structural failure
of the entire
object or system so there's a couple of
examples of this
uh on the right um at the top we have a
roof failure overblowing 737 aircraft
that occurred due to fatigue cracks uh
the bottom picture is more of a sandia
application this is from gts modeling or
gas transfer systems modeling
there's a surface flaw in a pressure
vessel it interacts with
the microstructure that's present there
and
that interaction may or may not lead to
to failure of the
ultimate of the vessel and um you know
it's really important to do this
modeling very carefully to make sure you
um
you make the right prediction of whether
or not the failure happens
um so because of the very tightly
coupled interaction between the small
and the large scales
for these types of problems what we
found is that concurrent multi-skill
methods are really
essential when trying to understand and
predict the behavior of
these um engineered systems and so
when i say concurrent methods i
essentially mean
methods that provide two-way coupling
where you have information propagating
back and forth concurrently between the
multiple scales that are involved
and so what we found is that if we don't
use these concurrent or two-way coupled
methods we don't always get an entirely
correct solution so we may not be able
to predict this failure for the
pressure vessel example correctly for
example
um so uh oh how do i make this top part
go away because you can probably
oh okay ah there it goes okay um
so uh this this present work is not our
first
foray into developing concurrent
multiple coupling methods
um this is a paper that was published in
2014 by my um
co-author alejandro moda um and his
collaborator
uh steve weitzman who used to be at
sandia and currently at
columbia university and so in this paper
um
stephen alejandro developed a
three-field multi-scale coupling
formulation
it achieves this concurrent coupling um
it enforces compatibility of the
discretization weekly using lagrange
multiplier so
it's a mixed discretization and if you
go through this um
there's a really nice formulation
there's some care to be taken to um
you know design all the uh spaces to
satisfy the lbb or in scoop conditions
so obviously there's some nuances with
that but
um you know they have a really nice
method that they
they've developed with nice results um
unfortunately
we weren't able to make use of this
method for our some of our production
problems
because it really proved to be too
difficult to implement into some of our
um
existing htc codes and so that was
really kind of the the main motivation
for the present work which
was aimed at developing a method that
would achieve some of these properties
like the concurrent
but that would be um easier for us to
put into
some of the codes that um we're using
for some of our um
so um that brings me to um our
list of requirements or kind of wish
list of properties for our multi-field
coupling method
i already talked about the first two
bullets so
we want the coupling to be concurrent or
two-way
we want the method to be easy to
implement into
some of our existing massively parallel
hpc codes
the third bullet we want the method to
be scalable fast and robust
on real engineering problems that we're
targeting so um
you know this isn't a case where we're
just trying to develop a method to write
a paper on it we actually want
the method to be impactful in our
mission spaces so we want the method to
go into our
production codes for analysts to use
them and you know for the method to
you know either enable them to do solve
problems faster
or you know solve more problems and
they're currently able to deal with
existing methods
um we're looking for a method that would
provide what i'm going to call
a plug-and-play framework that would
simplify the task of meshing complex
geometry so
i'll um kind of explain this in the
context of this picture at the bottom so
um this is kind of representative of
some of the problems that we're
um we're looking at solving so a lot of
problems that
are held together by fasteners here we
have these um these bolts
and you can imagine this can be a lot
more complicated than this picture with
a lot more bolts all over the place lots
more multi-scale components
um and um when you have a very complex
geometry like this just just meshing
this can be incredibly challenging so
it can take weeks to mesh one of these
things and requires a lot of meshing
expertise
um and so even though the meshing
operation is kind of a pre-processing
step
if you're looking to um you know study a
lot of different design configurations
let's say
this can actually be a big bottleneck
that can prevent you from doing a lot of
analyses that you may want to do
so we're looking for a method that would
allow us to take a multi-scale geometry
decompose it into
you know the large scales and the small
scales and then
kind of glue them together um and allow
you to mesh the the different components
separately
and it with this framework you know if
you want to change the mesh or if you
want to
change slightly one of these components
you can just um you know regenerate that
mesh separately and kind of plug it into
your your framework and
redo the simulation very easily um so
with that we want a method that would
allow us to couple regions with
different non-conformal meshes
different element types different levels
of refinement
um also allow us to use different
solvers and time integrators in
different regions
uh of course we don't want uh the
coupling to introduce any non-physical
artifacts
and then ideally the method would have
some theoretical convergence property or
guarantee
um so uh as the title suggests we're
proposing to do this coupling here using
the schwartz alternating method so
um i would guess that most people are at
least somewhat familiar with this method
but let me
kind of quickly go through how this uh
works um so then the method uh was
proposed in 1870 by herman schwartz for
solving the laplace equation on
irregular domains
it's um i think the earliest known
domain decomposition method
uh it's based on a really simple idea
namely if you want to solve a problem
on a complex domain you decompose that
domain into simpler
subdomains and then you use those uh
solutions in the simpler subdomains to
iteratively build a solution on the more
complex domain okay
so towards doing this before computers
um he was just um
analytically trying to derive these
solutions but um you know in the 20th
century
uh when computers came came about
obviously people tried to um
you know really make use of this method
to eat up computation
uh so i'll just go through kind of very
quickly how this
works in the context of this um
canonical two-domain example so i'll use
this throughout the
presentation this is without the
generality so you can have you know more
sophisticated
than you can have more than two domains
as well but let's say we have the
domain comprised of this circle and
rectangle okay
so the way the method works you're going
to start by solving your pde in the in
the circle we'll make a one
you're going to use the boundary
conditions that are prescribed on the
outer boundary
on this inner boundary gamma one um you
can use arbitrary boundary conditions to
get this started
i then go to omega2 um you're again
going to solve your pd and omega2
use prescribed boundary conditions on
the outer boundary and now on this inner
boundary gamma 2
you take your solution from omega 1 um
interpolate it onto gamma 2 um and use
that as the boundary condition
okay and then you go back to omega 1 and
you repeat
now you know for number 1 you're going
to have information from meter 2 rather
than something arbitrary
um and so this continues until the
solutions match to some tolerance within
the overlap region
and typically the information is
propagating through the boundary
conditions that's formulation
and so um not surprisingly um
since your uh your convergence criterion
has to do with um
the solutions being the same in the
overlap region the overlap region needs
to be non-empty
and kind of as you would expect the
larger the overlap region the fewer
iterations this will converge in so
if you have 100 overlap you're going to
converge in one iteration but you're not
really doing
fourths you're just solving your you
know single domain problem twice
basically so
that wouldn't be something you'd want to
do um
there would be kind of an optimal size
for that for a given problem for the
overlap region
um so where this method commonly comes
up is in the linear solver literature
where it's used very often as a
preconditioner for karla iterative
methods for solving
linear algebraic equations um the new
idea behind on a particular work
um that i'm presenting today is to use
the method
as a discretization method for solving
multi-scale pdes
okay and this is something that um you
know even though it's a very natural
thing to try to do
um not very many people had looked at
this prior to kind of us starting this
work and
certainly not at the the scales that
we're interested in so
um if you like memes my
co-author hundred likes mean so he made
the slide um you know we're kind of
scoffing at using that as a
pre-conditioner and instead advocating
using the method as a
um sort of solver for for a couple of
fully non-linear um
pe okay all right so that's the the
background
um there's no questions in the chat so
i'll um i'll continue to the next
section
um so like i said the the first kind of
part uh
main part of the talk is going to focus
on um
formulating method and discussing some
of its properties for quasi-static
problems and solid mechanics
um so let me kind of jump right into it
here um the top of the slide
shows the algorithm for um using
schwartz for quasi-static coupling
so before i go through this let me kind
of back up a little bit and
since i don't know what everyone's
background is online um
uh just to kind of give a little bit of
a background how quasi-statics work so
this is a
common approach in solid mechanics um
quasi-static kind of advancement of your
system um essentially the idea
is um you have a steady p and you're
going to solve a sequence of steady pds
and
with each new pde that you're solving
you're going to um
increment or augment the load that's
being applied to the system okay
so um you're sort of emulating dynamics
in some sense without having a gdt term
um in your equations and um you can um
you know potentially uh avoid some some
challenges that happen with dynamics
like cfl conditions by using this as
this type of an approach
um so uh the the short algorithm is at
the top here for the case of quasi
statics
you have an outer quad static loop
that's going to do this um
this uh increment incrementing of the
load that's being applied
and then within this loop you're going
to have your your schwarz loop
and so this is exactly the algorithm i
explained a few slides back just written
in mathematical notation
where you're basically solving back and
forth between the
two or more domains you have information
propagating through the boundaries
and then you um uh you don't go to the
next quasi-static step until you've
converted
the newton uh sorry the short step which
is based on how much the solutions match
in the overlap region
um so you can imagine you know this is
uh there's a number of advantages for
this kind of coupling it's conceptually
very simple
um so you just write this down in a few
lines um explain it in just a few
few sentences simple to understand
also kind of easy to put into a code um
you just kind of stick in this extra
loop inside your um
quasi-static glue that you already have
in there um it allows you to couple
different
uh regions with different non-conformal
meshes different element types different
levels of refinement
you're getting the concurrent coupling
because your information is
propagating between both of the domains
through the boundaries
you can use different solvers in
different regions you can use different
material models and different regions
under some conditions at all i'll talk
about a little later on
and then um this this achieves this goal
of
simplifying the task of measuring
complex geometries at different scales
since you can just mesh the different
domain separately and kind of glue them
together using the method
okay so um another uh
advantage as it turns out is that this
is based on a very solid theoretical
foundation
so just a little bit of a history of
some of the theory that's been done for
schwartz and
um one thing that's interesting is uh
the the theory depends on the pde that
you're looking at so
kind of as you go um down this list um
you know start with very simple linear
problems and go go to more sophisticated
problems with time so
um so will posed the method for linear
elasticity
um 1936 proved the methods convergence
1951 michelin
approved convergence of the method for
general linear elliptic bbs
um in the 80s leone really did some kind
of seminal work to try to get the method
back on the map
um including um you know applying the
method and formulating the method for
nonlinear problems and
improving convergence for nonlinear
monotone elliptic problems
um and then uh you know if you fast
forward a few more decades um
we had a paper uh three or four years
ago now
2021 already uh in 2017 in which we
proved convergence of the alternating
torts method for
finite deformation quasistatic nonlinear
pds
so i'll show the reference on the next
slide these are basically
steady mechanics problems that are
defined by this energy functional fee so
kind of for non-mechanics um folks out
there um
this is kind of defining the weak form
of your problem and um
you have uh here your um helpful free
energy density and embedded in this you
have a material model and so this can
really vary from um simple linear
elasticity to much more sophisticated
models
so um just to say a few words about the
um the theory uh so uh
this is a theorem that we have in our
paper which is cited at the bottom from
um the conditions for convergence of the
method is that the single domain problem
be
well posed and that the overlap region
be not empty
and i'm not going to go through how we
prove this because it takes about eight
pages in the paper so
that's what's in the background here but
essentially the idea is we construct a
sequence of solutions with the
uh curly feet till that n um and we show
that
uh that if we apply the short iteration
to the sequence
um we're going to converge to a unique
unique minimizer of the energy
functional capital fee
um and that the monitor converges okay
um and so we we leveraged some of the
analysis work done by it some of the
folks here
um you know sobel of and leon babushka
as well
um to to prove this okay
uh so um let me show uh kind of towards
showing some some examples let me talk a
little bit about implementation um
so like i said uh uh at the beginning we
we've implemented this method in two
codes um
for the quasi-static uh case i'm only
going to show results from one of the
codes but we actually um
have done all the problems that i'm
showing in both of the codes but so
there's really
it's just for kind of brevity to um you
know not not show duplicate results
um so the first code uh that that i'll
be showing results for is
is called albany lcm um so let me say a
little keywords about
what this code um what house code works
so this is an open source parallel
people's plus multiphysics fine and
element code
it's available on github at the url you
see here on the right
has a number of saline features it has a
component-based design that enables
rapid development of new physics and
capabilities so the components here are
primarily trilinos libraries these are
also open source
developed at sandia kind of the bread
and butter work
for the center for computing research at
sandia
and then albany houses what we call lcm
which is laboratory for computational
mechanics
um this is a kind of a suite that
contains a wide variety of constitutive
models
that range from you know simple linear
elasticity all the way to very
sophisticated
microstructure models like crystal
plasticity um
and so uh just in terms of the the role
of albany so
albany is actually both production code
and
kind of a sandbox code depending on the
application so we
have a landis model called um albany
landis living in in this code that's
hooked up to the doe
energy exact scalar system model that
some of you online may be familiar with
so for that application it's a
production code
for the solid mechanics application uh
we have another production code called
sierra
that i'll talk about later on so um here
the role of albany was really the kind
of prototype the method
and once we um we got the method working
well and kind of prototyped and albany
we went ahead and put it into our
productions with gr so
currently it's in both of the codes um
the last thing i wanted to say here was
about
the detail of the implementation so one
of the things that's not entirely
trivial
in the implementation of the method is
um
how you would do the search and
interpolation when you're going from
one domain onto the boundary of the
other subdomain and in particular this
is not entirely trivial to do
in in parallel and so for this we're
relying on a library called gtk data
transfer kit
um this is out of oak ridge national lab
um and this is a really nice kind of
easy to use library that um
uh we were able to integrate into the
code pretty quickly and um
that it gives us a really scalable kind
of fast and
implementation that i'll show some
results for later on
okay so uh numerical examples so i'm
gonna i'm gonna show um four examples
here and
these are gonna start with um very
simple proof of concept problems just to
kind of verify the method
verify some of its properties and then
all the other production-like problems
so the first example is really really
simple um i call this the cuboid problem
um we have the coupling of two cuboids
with a square base shown at the top
the the goal here is to look at what
happens with the method as we change the
um
level of refinement in each of these
cuboids and um we also
we also change the size of the overlap
region we're going to put a new hookian
type of material model here which is a
nonlinear elastic material model and
we're going to pull on this from the top
stretch um so i'll let me let me show a
few results for this um
the first thing i actually wanted to
talk through is this picture at the
bottom so it just gives you um some
intuition about how this works the
duration works
so basically initially you have some
error in the overlap region
um and then you know as the iterations
progress this air eventually will get
corrected
um so that's just kind of some intuition
about how the iteration and the method
works
um so uh first result has to do with
um looking at convergence as you change
the overlap and
the level of refinement in the in the
cubewoods um
so the the last time here um this is
looking at convergence for uh different
mesh sizes and a fixed
overlap volume fraction which is the
size of the overlap region
um this is plotting essentially kind of
errors into subsequent towards iteration
um and so so that the the slope of this
line is the convergence uh rate
and you can see we get a um a linear
convergence rate and that that result is
consistent with our theoretical results
that we derived in that
2017 paper that i mentioned uh on the
right we're looking at what happens as
you
um change the size of the overlap region
so the overlap volume fraction
and so um we're plotting in this in this
plot um what we call the convergence
factor view so it's kind of the ratio of
errors into
um just two subsequent iterations um
and there's a lot of stuff happening
here in the in the legend but
just just to i'll just give you the main
conclusion from this what this
this reveals is that we get a faster
linear convergence
as we increase the size of the overlap
volume fraction so you know the larger
the overlap the fewer iterations you'll
converge in
that's again kind of consistent with the
theory and with what you would
intuitively expect to happen um we can
also compute errors so we computed
errors with respect to a reference
solution and each of the cuboids
uh displacement errors are basically a
machine precision in the stresses the
errors are
10 to the minus 13 um so you're really
not
getting any error introduced by the the
coupling
so that was a really simple problem so
let's not go to a more spirited problem
so this is what i call the notch
cylinder problem
um here's our geometry and the left two
pictures um to match
cylinder we're gonna stretch this um
along the axial direction from the top
and the bottom and again it's going to
stretch like the cube would again we use
this new hokkien type of material model
which is
an elastic non-linear model so the
natural thing to do here for our delay
decomposition would be to make this
middle domain uh middle middle region
one domain um and then the the rest of
this the
second domain um this is actually one
domain we we only solved the sun and
eighth of this for
use so much using symmetry conditions so
uh there's any confusion there that
that's
the reason for this thing just one
domain um but um
so the natural thing you'd want to do
here it would be to put a really fine
mesh in the middle
since that's where um you know all the
conaction is expected to happen with the
simulation
and then we're going to put a relatively
coarse mesh away from this middle part
and so we're going to look at coupling
different um
different element types and uh so we're
going to put uh type elements here and a
couple
of those two hex elements um away from
the middle and you can see the
resolutions are quite different from the
meshes
um so this is the movie um that shows
you what happened so i have the
displacement magnitude on the left
um one of the koshi stress components on
the right and
this is a really large deformation
problem i should mention
um and so you can see you know you get a
nice solution with information
um propagating um you know correctly
uh between the the two domains oops okay
um so that was kind of an eyeball norm
uh statement so we can also quantify
this
um this is reporting errors in the in
the displacement the errors are about
0.1 percent
now um what's kind of interesting here
uh if you visualize the errors you can
actually see that
most of the errors uh here are not
coming from the coupling
so if you look at the earth um splat
plot in these two pictures
okay most of the errors where you see
the curvature in the domain
and if you think about this it actually
makes sense what's happening so
this is a curved geometry our reference
solution that we're computing errors
with respect to is shown here
um against the wrong side of it but but
this is a much finer mesh so it's able
to
better represent this curve geometry so
what you're seeing in most of this error
is actually just geometric error
that you would you would have with just
a standard find element discretization
so it's not really due to the coupling
at all
um okay so uh we also
as i mentioned earlier we also are able
to couple different
material models under some conditions
let me kind of show that on an example
so this is the same problem or variant
of the same problem we're going to put
an
elastic material model in the course
region
elastic plastic material model in the
fine region we have hex meshes measured
on but that doesn't matter for the
illustration
um so essentially uh what you need to do
when you're
doing different material models you need
to be a little bit careful to do the
domain decomposition so that the
material models are consistent in the
overlap region
okay so this is showing two domain
decompositions a good one on the left
and
a bad one on the right so in the good
one that the overlap is far from the
notch
there's no plastic deformation in it so
you get a nice smooth solution so
you kind of get everything that the the
course and foundations are predicting
the same behavior and the overlap so
everything is kind of good here
um if you put the overlap too close to
the notch
um plastic deformation will spill onto
the overlap region the the models
predict different behavior and you can
have an adverse effects on convergence
um so you know you do see some artifacts
here and
the the theory we have assumes the same
material model i do think that it can be
extended if you have some compatibility
in the overlap region but it just shows
you that um
you know you do need to take a little
bit of care to sort of design the the
domain decomposition in
the right way especially when you're
having different material models
that's kind of an ongoing research area
actually how to do that in general
um so uh moving towards production-like
problems example through the laser world
problem
so here we're looking at um a couple of
more than two domains just to illustrate
that that's possible to do
um so we have three subdomains in red
gray and green here um coupling
isotropic elasticity with g2 plasticity
um we're able to get about a 50
reduction in the model size here
relative to a single domain
discretization
um while keeping the air uh to the same
tolerance
and one of the objectives of this
problem was also to look at the scaling
of this to look at the scaling
strong scaling with this parallel
implementation that uses dtk
so you can see we get a near ideal speed
of linear speed up for for this problem
for
several different mesh resolutions that
we were considering um
so then the last problem is is kind of a
our production problem or the one that i
chose to highlight we have others as
well that we've done
this is a work by um some of my
colleagues at sandia um coleman allman j
folks dave littlewood and guy burgel and
i think this is an interesting problem
because
it illustrates a really interesting use
case of the method
namely that the method can be used as
part of a homogenization or upscaling
process to bridge the gap between
microscopic and macroscopic regions
okay so um here's the the idea so we
have this um temple geometry
we're going to embed in this
microstructure in the middle the the
goal here is is that is to study strain
localization within the microstructure
um and so kind of the the motivation for
the upscaling is basically if you can
think of this microstructure model as a
very detailed model
that you're not going to be able to
afford to use everywhere in the domain
okay
so um we're going to take this model
we're going to couple it to a simpler
model
we're going to couple this crystal
plasticity model for the microstructure
to a
j2 plasticity model for the rest of this
that's our macro scale model
um you're going to use this use us to do
that coupling and we're going to try to
inform the
macro scale model using the
microstructure information that's what i
mean by um
upscaling for those who aren't familiar
with that um
so uh what we're doing we're going to do
is we um or i guess now we
coleman did the study um he prescribed
an ensemble of uniaxial loads to the
structure
um he had ten uh ensembles of this
crystal plasticity model
so you can see them here on this plot um
that's showing cool plastic strain and
stress
and basically he just fit the the j2
plasticity model to the set of ensemble
to do the the upscaling so
um this is i think a really neat kind of
powerful um
for the method um so with that i'll kind
of
end the quasi-static part so let me see
um
uh i don't know do we want to take a
couple questions now or should i just
say them all for the end
it's up to you irina we have a two
questions
i believe or three or two yeah
it's up to you i'm looking at that maybe
i'll wait until the end because i think
these are kind of more broad questions
rather than
um rather than ones that are specific to
the quality stacks but
let's maybe just wait until the end that
way i'll be sure to get through
everything and
that sounds good okay so um so the last
part here um
is going to be on dynamics so
essentially um a few years
a few years back after we kind of got
good results for the quasi-statics case
we
we moved on to extensive methods of
dynamics and so
um again i'll uh um kind of start with a
little bit of a
motivation here so we um uh
we did a literature research when we
started this work for dynamics um
we uh there were some short-sized
methods out there that we came across
most of these were based on space-time
discretizations
where you basically treat time as an
auxiliary spatial dimension
and so um you know as with everything
there's some advantages and some
disadvantages
so this lets you use um non-matching
meshes and different time steps in
different regions which is what we
ultimately want to do
um unfortunately um you know again
our methods really are our codes aren't
really um designed to work
well with you know to be to allow
space-time methods to be easily
integrated into them so
these kinds of this flavor methods
really weren't feasible for us given the
design of our codes and the size of the
simulations that we're running
um so that prompted us to develop kind
of our own
um formulation of schwartz for dynamics
that will work from with more
traditional
discretizations methods where you first
discretize in space and discretize in
time
um so let me kind of talk through how
this works so
kind of the main ingredients are as
follows so you have your domain
decomposition like before
um you're going to have discretizations
in each of these domains you're going to
have
discretizations in space and also in
time and so just like the
spatial discretizations don't need to be
the same the temporal discretizations
also don't need to be the same and and
the time steps don't need to be the same
um the last ingredients are shown in
blue so i call this the controller time
stepper
and the the idea here is basically just
define some global time steps at which
you're going to synchronize your sub
domains
and this just um basically gives you a
way to um
you know have the the method converge
for for a small
relatively small time step without
having to go all the way to the end of
your
simulation before checking for
convergence and synchronizing the
domains and
hopefully that'll become clear as i go
through the algorithm so um
here's how this goes you initialize the
first controller time step
um you're going to um figure solution
omega 1 you're going to advance from t0
to mp1
um in doing that you're going to need
information from omega 2 on gamma
1 and notice that this is going to need
interpolation in
space but but also potentially in time
so if your omega two uses different time
steps you're going to need to
interpolate
onto this boundary in time as well
that's an important detail
uh even go to omega2 um you're going to
repeat again you're going to need to
interpolate from omegle 1 to gamma
2 in space and potentially in time
uh when both of the domains are reached
time t1 you're going to check for
convergence
and if the method is not converged you
return to step one when you repeat
if the method is converged you go to the
next controller time step and you repeat
okay and so um again i emphasize you can
use different integrators different time
steps within each uh domain
um there's an important detail here that
when we we found that when we do this
interpolation um it was important to
actually
interpolate not just the displacement
but also the velocity and the
acceleration
for the dynamics case um in order to
kind of get the best results so that
that was kind of an important
another important detail if you're using
different different time steps you do
need to um
kind of take some care to store the
solution at different time steps and
have the capability to interpolate the
solution in time so
it's another kind of important detail um
oh i'm gonna make this go away again
i should ah there it goes
a little bit about theory like before so
like for the quasi-static case
um we're able to show convergence under
some conditions
um the conditions are similar we can
show convergence if the problem single
domain problem is well closed
and the overlap region is not empty we
also have some conditions on the time
step delta t
um so you know the details can be found
in this paper at the bottom that we
submitted a few months back to kumami
um just to kind of sketch out how we
prove this we look at the action
functional s which is the integral
of the lagrangian over space and time
um we want this to be strictly convex or
strictly concave
and we study this by looking at the
second variation of the action function
and so um you know skipping all the
details here what we're able to show is
if we use a new mark time integration
scheme which is the usual
time integration scheme that's used for
these problems um for the fully discrete
problems here's how our
second variation of the action function
looks like so
m is the mass matrix k is the stiffness
matrix gamma and beta are new mark
parameters and delta t is the time step
and basically if you kind of stare at
this for a while you can see um
this can always be made positive if you
choose a sufficiently small delta wt
okay so this is something you could
check for a given discretization
uh and what we found in our numerical
experiments is that usually the
time step requirements for stability and
accuracy will automatically lead to
satisfaction of this bound
so um let me let me show examples again
so um
uh more on implementation so i mentioned
earlier um
we have this other codes here solid
mechanics that i haven't talked about
yet so let me let me talk about that so
um for the dynamics case i'm going to
show results in albany lcm that i
already covered and also the sierra code
um so what is sierra it's a sandia
lagrangian 3d code for the finite
element analysis of solids and
structures
has a lot of different um squeeze or
components that are shown in this
picture we're using just a few of them
we're using adagio and presto
for quasi statics and impulsive explicit
dynamics so
like i said before we we have
quasi-static since here i just just
happened not to show those results in
this presentation
um and then the other the other piece
that we're using is not in this picture
um but it's in sierra
it's called arpeggio and so arpeggio is
a loose coupling framework that exists
in sierra um
it was designed for multiphysics
coupling like um
doing thermal mechanical coupling for
instance um but we were able to
to hijack this framework to do the
schwartz implementation and what was
really um a pleasant surprise for us is
we actually did not have to write any
code in sierra
to implement schwarz so we were just
able to use that arpeggio coupling
and basically create input files for the
coupling to perform all the steps of the
of the schwarz method as i described it
for both the quasi-statics and the
dynamics so that was
kind of um really a very pleasant
surprise for us because we didn't really
want to you know get too deep into into
sierra which is a
very big complex code uh
so again examples also three this time
um again they'll go from
proof of concept all the way to
production type problems
um first problem like before it's really
simple this is um
elastic wave propagation problem we have
a linear elastic clamped beam with a
gaussian
initial condition so this is a beam
here's the initial condition in blue
for the z displacement um this is going
to kind of split into two gaussians and
and reflect off the wall and eventually
get this mirror image gaussian i'll show
a movie in the next slide
um it's a really simple problem it has
an exact analytical solution
but um it turns out it's a very
stringent test for um
discretization methods um and so we're
going to look at two subdomains one from
zero to 0.7514.25 to 1.
uh we're going to use look at all kinds
of different couplings so implicit
explicit um hextech
and so on so i'll just show some results
so this is looking at a variety of
different couplings with the same delta
t but but different
different time integrators and different
discretization so there's a couple
movies here i'll just play them as i
talk
um so this is showing the z displacement
z velocity
uh red and green are the schwarz
solutions and then
blue is the single domain solution and
so as this plays you can see the
solutions pretty much match
the entire um time and um you know there
there are some oscillations here and
there but
you see those in the single domain
solutions and this is some dispersion
from the time integration scheme um so
that's that's not an artifact that comes
out of the schwartz so
we're not seeing any artifacts or
pervasive and other coupling methods
and again this is an eyeball norm
statement we can
make this more rigorous by computing
errors with respect to the exact
solution
so these are summarized in the table for
different couplings um
cm is uh consistent mass lm is lumped
mass so that's um
uh with the lump lumping you get a
little bit less accurate solution but
basically these numbers are comparable
to what you would have with um
coupling with a single domain
discretization having a comparable um
time step and spatial resolution and um
that uh
pre-print paper has had those results i
didn't include them here but
i refer you to the paper if you'd like
to um verify that
uh so um a little bit of performance
data even though it's a really simple
problem um
so this is showing a number of maximum
and average number of short iterations
during the run for different couplings
with different um schwarz tolerances so
um really i just wanted to point out
that the schwarz tolerance is something
that you can
use as a knob so you know as you as you
tighten the schwarz tolerance
the number of iterations required to
converge will go up as
you would expect um you know if you
loosen it
it goes down so you know if you're um if
your method is too slow you could try to
loosen the tolerance to get it to go
faster if you feel like it's not
accurate enough you could tighten the
tolerance
that's a that's a knob that one has in
addition to the size of the overlap
region
um it's kind of fun for this to look at
how the number of iterations changes in
time so
you know initially um when uh kind of
you don't really need the two domains
just to communicate because the gaussian
isn't just
you know one of them uh or sorry the
gaussian is not in the in the overlapped
region
you're converging in just just two
iterations and then you know
as the gaussian kind of hits the overlap
region this this goes up
um you know you're back to it back to
two when kind of nothing is really
happening and you don't really need the
domains to
communicate so much and then goes back
up um when you get the mirror image of
the gaussian in the overlap region
um so that that last example i had the
same delta t
throughout one of the advantages of the
method is it allows you to use different
delta t's as well which would be
something you may want to do if you're
coupling implicit and explicit steppers
since you should be able to use a much
larger time step in the implicit domain
than the explicit one
so let's let's see what happens there so
here we have an implicit
step or recover a couple to an explicit
stepper drastically different time steps
so one e minus two
and x was a domain and two minus seven
and the sorry
one e minus two in the implicit domain
two e minus seven in the explicit domain
and these are the few of the solutions
superimposed over each other and there's
also a single domain solution here that
you can't see
since everything um they're all kind of
on top of each other so
again you're you're not um you know
everything is indistinguishable the
short solutions are indistinguishable
from the single domain and the analytic
solution
so um we're not seeing any artifacts
even in the case of different
drastically different time steps to use
um so the last two examples are
um kind of more more production-like
examples so they're from our production
code sierra
uh this is a tension specimen problem so
it's a little bit similar to
um the notch cylinder uh kind of set up
um
we have a uniax aluminum cylindrical
tensile specimen here
we have now um an inelastic j2 material
model which has a lot of these internal
variables that need to be um
kind of dealt with correctly that was a
little bit of a challenge to do that
correctly
um within the albany implementation we
were doing it um
so uh we're going to decompose this into
two subdomains that
i'll call them the ends and the gauge um
we're going to put a
fine high order 10 no tetrahedral mesh
and the gauge
couple that to a um a hex mesh
uh away from or in the ends as i call
them and this um
this this mesh that we're using here
this is a special element we developed
for solid mechanics that's called the
the
composite um uh 10 no tetrahedron
um we're going to use implicit uh time
stepping for this um
we're going to put a really slight
imperfection exactly in the middle of
this so that when we when we pull on
this from both ends which will be the
um the the loading applied um we're
this is going to neck exactly in the
middle um so
for the kind of non-solid mechanics
folks this is um
what i mean by the necking and kind of
what we expect for the results so
initially
you're in this elastic strain region
this is just gonna kind of stretch
without having
um kind of a noticeable deformation
eventually you're gonna get um into this
plastic strain region
you're gonna see this necking behavior
so it's gonna get very thin in the
middle and eventually you're gonna get a
fracture there
so here's what we get for the simulation
um this is y displacement on the left
equivalent plastic strain on the right
um you get this necking behavior in the
middle um and we're able to
um converge in just three short
iterations per time step so
it's quite um quite quite small um
some more eye candy kind of the same
result just um visualize differently um
global plastic strain again
you can see how it changes based on
which domain you're in
uh and then um koshi stress as well
so um you know the stress is maximal in
the middle so that's going to tell you
that this is where the fracture is going
to happen which is what you would you
would expect
see oh okay i'm going on time um so uh
last example
um so this is what i call the the
voltage joint problem and this is where
i kind of started and so this is where i
wanted to um
to end as well um so i already kind of
presented this geometry and some of the
motivation
um this is really representative of some
of the problems we want to solve so we
have a group of folks that
are called the fastener group and so
they're they're interested in um
you know modeling these these um
geometries that have bolts and other
fasteners kind of holding pieces
together which are
very relevant to some of the um the nw
mission spaces that
that they work on um this is the kind of
an innocuous example of it though so
this is our um
uh our computational domain on the left
is
an example of where you might see this
in the real world this is a lamppost
um so we're going to decompose this into
the small and the large scales um
the the small scales are the bolts we're
going to put a
composite to 10 mesh in the bolts um
couple that to a hex mesh in the
remainder of this which i'll call the
the parts um we're again using this this
inelastic g2 material model in both of
the domains we have
uh the bolts are steel the the um the
parts have a steel component and an
aluminum component as well
um so let's let's see what happens we're
going to apply an
x displacement so from left to right and
this this to this geometry so here's
what what happens
um single domain solution is on the left
just horse solution is on the right
single domain solution is on an all
composite type 10 mesh because you
actually can't mesh this with the texas
um if it's if you're not doing the you
know something like schwartz
because of the the bolts being so kind
of detailed um
and so i call this the um backing into a
pole problem
so uh supposed to be a joke but can't
tell online if
people are laughing but especially i i
came came across this deformed
configuration of san francisco parking
garage so
um uh you know someone someone did this
experiment
uh it wasn't me for the record i was
quite happy that i could compare to some
um experimental
uh you know quote experimental results
i'm sure they they weren't quite so
happy when they did this to their car
but
uh in any case you can see you know some
of this behavior like the lifting of the
you know this part in this part you
actually see that in the in this
instruction and the
single domain and tour solutions are um
essentially the same
uh you can also look at equivalent
plastic strain in the bowls um
so you know you can see these things are
kind of getting sheared and i think
eventually the top part would probably
pop off if we continue this
um very much of interest is some some
some results about sort of convergence
and performance so
um convergence rate for this problem so
we plotted errors into subsequent
iterations
we get a linear convergence rate for
this which is comparable to what we had
for
the um quasi-static uh case that i
showed
and then um i think this is very
interesting this is some data about
performance so
we had um four different uh
discretizations here so
the first two have the single domain
schwartz they have a comparable number
of
uh elements in the bolts and then the
second two also have a comparable number
of elements in the
in the bolts and the meshes are finer
here essentially for the bulb
so um there's some interesting results
here so first if you look at the first
two lines
you can see excuse me that even though
the schwarz method is iterative
it can actually be faster than the
single domain run um
for example having a comparable number
of elements in the bolts
and that's actually kind of surprising
because it is an iterative method so you
would think that it would be slower
but i think what's happening here is
basically your single domain problems
are easier to solve than your
coupled problem and then that together
with the fact that we're not
converting very many iterations causes
us to be more
um fit to be faster um the story is
different if you look at the second two
lines here so
here um schwartz kind of loses it's
lower than the single domain problem
um but i emphasize that um you know the
method may still be preferred for its
ability to rapidly change and evaluate a
variety of engineering designs which is
our typical
use case at sandia and we're actually
still trying to kind of understand
you know when the method quote-unquote
wins versus not what kinds of problems
with the help of some of these analysts
that i mentioned who
are running these um voltage joint type
problems
um the other thing i already alluded to
so this is converging in a very small
number of iterations
between two and four that's actually a
little bit surprising because the
overlapping here is really tiny so i
didn't show it before but it's just this
region around the bolts
so that was a little bit curious that
it's still so fast even though
the overlap is so small um so that's uh
again how do i make this top of uh i
don't know how to make this go away uh
okay well i guess it's okay uh let's see
so so let me um let me kind of wrap up
um so
i i talked about the schwartz method
and its development at sandia for
concurrent multi-scale coupling in
quasi-statics and dynamics
i've talked about implementation of the
method in two codes albany lcms
are solid mechanics we get all of these
requirements that i mentioned at the
beginning so the concurrent coupling
ease of implementation skill method
being scalable fast and robust um
creating a plug-and-play framework with
the method that simplifies task emission
complex geometries um numerical
artifacts and
theoretical convergence properties um so
i just wanted to end by saying a few
words about what we're still doing with
the method so
we're still very much involved in this
work so current
current work is is centered on um
continuing to apply the method to
problems of interest to production using
mostly sierra solid mechanics at this
point within sandia
um i i would invite um so i i believe
i'm not sure if
lawrence livermore folks can use sierra
but certainly the albany sam
implementation is open first so
if anyone is interested in um giving
that a try
um you know we're definitely willing to
work with you guys to help you
you know set up the code and set up the
types of problems that you want to
um to run you know to hopefully make use
of the method to to simply to
help some of your computations as well
um where uh
we've done a little bit of work on
trying to advance the method to couple
structural elements to continuum
elements so the structural elements
would be like um
shell elements for instance um and then
the big
task as of this fiscal year is
we're developing a schwarz-like
algorithm for simulating contact
to address some of the well-known
challenges in numerical simulation of
context so
things like um content constraint
enforcement the multiple scales that are
involved
and just to give you some flavor for
this we're looking at a non-overlapping
formulation
kind of like this and so for that you
need to change the transmission
conditions you need either
alternating duraclean neumann or rob and
robin type of conditions
um and so a big part of this research is
going to be kind of
understanding what are the optimal
conditions to use in this
non-overlapping framework for the for
the contact application
um and then this is just kind of a
further down the line so it's a little
bit of kind of my vision for this
ultimately um so i i think um
you know developing a multi-physics
coupling framework first
would be um very interesting and useful
where you could do
um you can imagine different kinds of
multi-focus coupling you could do
things with total overlap like thermal
mechanical coupling or no overlap like
um
fluid structure interaction um and i
think uh this picture really kind of
summarizes the vision where
um ultimately the method can also be
used to
provide a rigorous coupling framework
for conventional and data-driven models
so
i would imagine you know coupling
find it element and finite volume type
models let's say with um
reduced models or even neural networks
so projection-based reducer models are
things like physics and form neural
networks where you have
potentially different models or
different physics and different
sub-domains
and you have this fourth glue kind of
holding everything together
um so obviously for this you know these
transmission conditions are going to
change and so i think there will be a
lot of work in trying to
come up with um how to do those
conditions for the various types of
models
um we're trying to get some funding for
this sort of work right now so hopefully
we'll
be able to pursue it in the near near
future um so that's the
pretty much the end um here are
references um the last two are
are the references that i alluded to
that that that we've um
we've published or submitted and if
you're interested in the preprint of the
dynamic paper this is um available on my
website which is shown here
um so i'll i'll stop here um let's see
uh oh wow okay last time i thought but
i'm happy to take questions sorry that
it's a little
longer than i expected but um i think
we have a list of questions in the chat
room if you can
go over that and quickly answer them
that would be nice
i do okay so one from henry u
uh i do facial modeling in my work
wherein irregular domains are handled by
a mask function one within and zero
outside defined on the grid
i wonder what is the advantage of
schwartz over this
masking method
okay so i i would have to maybe
know more about the um
the the method um does the method a lot
i mean it sounds like
you would have the same mesh for both of
the questions
um maybe maybe that's not right uh
i guess i don't know if people can can
speak during the seminar or not but
it sounds to me like maybe with this
method you wouldn't you wouldn't be able
to
mesh the two parts separately but i
could be wrong
um so so i i would think that that might
be one advantage
that chords would allow you to use
different meshes and you they would not
need to be conformal um
so i think maybe that's something that
we would
talk about more offline so i don't know
henry if you want to send me an email or
we definitely check more about it
offline but some of the details
of what what your method actually does
because i i i think i need to
need to know a little bit more about
about how it works um
what are advantages over of this method
over
time slide surfaces um
so i guess okay i'm not sure what you
mean by are you
are you referring is this referring to
sort of tied contact
uh yes yes oh tied contest uh
well so okay so i guess i i i'm also
so the the contact part we haven't done
with with the method
um the contact is something we're
tackling uh now
um i think so i mean
i guess when i think of sort of tie
contact or contact i think of that as a
non-overlapping framework where this
framework is overlapping
um i think you you actually could
formulate
so we started looking at the
non-overlapping version of this now for
contacts
um you do need to change the
transmission conditions for that
you you could actually there are kind of
non-overlapping versions of
of the well i guess already said this
was the method with with different
conditions
we haven't actually looked at we haven't
compared
the overlapping version to the
non-overlapping version for the purpose
of
multi-scale coupling um that's something
that we
are starting to look at now so so that
may be something that
um that comes up there but um i think
the conditions would have to change
um within the schwartz coupling if
you're going to have it the
non-overlapping like it's
like what i'm thinking of when you're
when you mentioned the the tide slide
surfaces
um let's see uh okay that one our answer
in time interpolation does this mean
that you will need to extrapolate from
the course
to fine time step um
so you may need to do some ex well
okay i guess it depends on let me go to
the slide
so what i mean oh where is it
too many slides here all right
so um essentially what what i mean by by
interpolation is
so let's say um let's say that you're
you're you're in the second domain which
has a smaller time step
you're going to need to so in your in
your first domain you only had
the the solution here and here and
you're going to need to somehow
get it at this time so
i guess i i don't really call that
extrapolation
i would still you're you're not going to
go to some
like well i guess it depends on how you
define extrapolation but but you're
my concern was the next green line so
when you go back to the green domain
at the third time step so how
are you going to then project are you
going to do
the third time step of red and then
interpolate back to the to the green or
does the green like i guess it's just
the coupling is because it's a question
because
you have you know four lines for the
green and three for the red
so these lines are meant to be the time
step right
the third time step of the green how
where did that boundary condition come
from is an interpolation of having
finished the red
well so okay it is from the red but the
red will have already gotten to t1
so it will take this guy and this guy
okay that was it that was a simple yeah
yeah yeah so i don't i don't consider it
extrapolation because
that's that's the kind of the idea yeah
thanks for clarifying
of this controller time step because one
domain will have reached this before you
go to the
next one so it's it's not really
extrapolation in that sense
but yeah that's that's kind of this is a
little bit of a nuance in detail with
how you do that but
yeah good good question the question
though but it seems to me then i don't
know how you interpolate from the two
the second and third green time step
back to the second time step in the red
which i think you have is arrows in um
your next so there is presumably at the
red you have interpolated from two of
the green but you know
but you haven't gotten the third green
time step because you haven't
completed all of the red time steps i
guess it was just confusing from the
schematic and maybe i'm just like
yeah well so i think the idea is that
the green
when you're doing this the green has
already made it to t1
so you would use these two
for the red the second time that makes
sense
yeah no worries it may be we spent a
while on this animation it was supposed
to make it easier but there may be some
some confusion with it so i apologize
for that um
let's see um ah
okay that one i answered william
sorry the next question is william elmer
yeah is there a limit oh i'm not reading
who's advancing i'm sorry about that um
william elmer is there a limit where the
overlap is so small that the stability
limit showed it dominates over those
the individual domains and is so is that
is that limit more than an element width
of the fine mesh
so um i think you're talking about the
the stability limit for for for this
you mean the dynamic one this one here i
assume is that
is that what you're referring to um
so i mean the smaller the overlap the
more iterations the method will converge
in and i think if it's
if it's getting really really small then
you may have some issues
kind of with um the boundary conditions
not being the right ones
we we haven't really um we haven't done
this limiting case
because um i guess our our aim mostly uh
has been sort of to come up with
decompositions that would be
that would make sense for the problems
that our analysts are running so
um the the case i showed with the the
voltage joint the overlap is very small
there it's not in this limit
but um we just we haven't had a need to
look at that that limit case
practically because in practice people
aren't usually going to do a domain
decomposition like this so they haven't
had to
um it would be interesting to look at
that like to do maybe a more thorough
numerical study to go along with the
theory certainly so that may be
something to
look at um i i think
you're right that there probably would
be something something you know there
may be some issues if you get to really
small
very tiny overlaps like you say um
henry you uh again so if it seems the
goal of schwartz method is to handle
differently matched regions find both
course not just a regular shape
is that correct yes that is correct yeah
so one of the motivations
is to simplify the task of matching
these complex geometries and to let you
basically
um kind of plug and play with different
pieces so that you can um
you know mesh different parts separately
and if you want to sketch them a little
bit and swap them out for other pieces
you can um
you can um easily do that with the
coupling framework
could this method handle subtractive
geometry
chris golas so what do you mean by
subtractive geometry
if you wanted to make a hole in a piece
like you have been showing
oh that's so you're saying like one
geometry is embedded in the other is
that
or in a negative way
um i guess i so
the the the embedded part i think we've
been asked this before
i think you can do that we haven't tried
it i guess i don't i don't know
how what what you mean by i mean you
wouldn't if it's if it's subtracted you
wouldn't have a pde in it right
so i don't i don't know if i understand
the
practical use case of that but um
i i you can you can fully embed the
geometry that's that's actually a really
good question we haven't tried it but
but we've thought about that i think you
should be able to do that with the
method
but um yeah i guess subtractive i i
don't quite because i mean the method
requires you to have different pdes and
so if you're just
cutting out a piece then that would just
change your geometry i mean you wouldn't
you wouldn't have a
you know you just wouldn't have anything
in the subtracted
region i would think so i guess i'm not
i'm not sure i
know when that would be kind of useful
but um
non-overlapping would be directly to
neumann schwartz yes i agree so
um there are directly yeah so directly
to neumann there's a lot of different
formulations here um
gander has looked a lot of this a lot of
different leones has looked a lot of
that at this um
you can do either rob and robin
conditions you can do um also
alternating you know jericho annoying
and your clinium and that type of thing
and
there are a lot of regularization
parameters that you may want to kind of
tweak in that so
um so there's lots lots to like to do
there for the non-overlapping
um oh 542 i guess
okay i think i think that we're probably
way over time now and um
just pretty much cover everything i
think so irena
well let's thank you so much for the
great talk and great
uh the research uh it's really exciting
to see your
awesome work uh and yeah it's been
reached out to me if people have more
questions or if people are interested
feel free to email me um
or we can set up another spread meeting
to talk more if you'd like more
information
exactly exactly well thank you thank you
so much for staying
over time both irina you and the
audiences
but i think some of the the folks who
asked the question on the chat room they
actually left because they
have other things to do and so some of
them
couldn't probably hear your answers i
will try to
i will try to connect the the the person
who asked the question and
with with you irina email so that you
can be connected
and then continue the discussion but
otherwise uh thank you so much
and both irina you and the audiences and
and i think it was a great talk thank
you thank you
thank you all right well next
next seminar will be the january 21st
and until then stay safe and stay
healthy
all right bye everyone